jean dominici c'est la femme de
christophe qui vous a prévenu de sa
disparition
non sinon comment vous l'avez appris ce
jour là je regardais une émission d'ora
l'équilibré et j'avais pas me garder la
télé vous avez pas milliers
d'informations et ça ça passe et je
crois de suite
/ / / / une émission elle a le meilleur
ami de mon de mon fils m'appelle et me
dit jeannot comment ça va un peu surpris
parce que je m'appelle rarement et de la
vie pour agassi à coucou n'auriez jamais
non monsieur juste pour savoir il
raccroche un deuxième mon neveu pareil
ils me disent ah non comment ça va très
bien ouais je commence il faut dire que
c'est beau qu'est ce qu'il ya non rien
non mais tu veux je te rappellerai pas
d'ailleurs at elle écrit à une personne
qui appelle ma femme une copine qui me
dit nicole j'ai ma nièce qui est de voir
ça sur sur sur face book ou sur facebook
que christophe est mort comme ça alors
là moi je dise pas possible c'est pas
possible
et puis alors là je vois arriver tous
ses copains parce qu'on habite dans un
village tous ses copains qui jouaient
robien et lutz a qui rêvent tous à la
maison et moi je sais plus où je suis
j'appelle de suite le l'ancien fiancé de
ma fille quand on est resté très très
très ami de toujours à bennoo quand il
s'est marié
un enfant c'est comme si c'était le
nôtre dit pierre bien vite on parle de
six appareils et 4h 5h je suis parti à
paris
tu as l'air de dire du matin et ma belle
fille m'a jamais appelé alors moi je
j'essaie de téléphoner 2 partout
j'essaie d'appeler sa secrétaire
j'essaie de même pas aller me re je
pouvais et une deux une ancienne femme
de ménage qu'il avait elle le voit elle
voit le voit ça la radio
elle habite à côté d'eux vient vite à la
maison et j'appelle la maison et je
tombe sur cette île mais qu'est-ce qui a
castilla
je savais rien je vous dit votre fils et
voilà peut-être spectateurs 2005 curling
m'appelle il m'a dit jeannot qu'elles
sont morts voilà c'est comme ça que vous
avez appris la le décès de votre fils
alors selon une source policière il
aurait volontairement sauté d'un parapet
en béton aux 20 mètres et pour ses
proches
la thèse du suicide est difficile à
croire bernard on peux pas le croire
c'est une étude d'une évidence il sauf
ils avaient tous étaient heureux ils
étaient sur les dents c'est business
sensible à se dessiner c'est passé c'est
impossible quoi c'est possible ou alors
comme joli sens il ya une chose qui nous
a échappé mais pour moi c'était possible
et puis je vais choquer je ne reviendrai
jamais cette idée là c'est ma plus chic
non mais quand quand vous dites c'est
impossible bernard quel est l'autre
hypothèse alors penser que c'est un
accident qu'il aurait glissé qu'il
aurait oui il se donnait un parapet et
moi j'aime moi dans ma tête je me dis
c'est à bougie le quoi il a glissé ces
deux thèmes possibles effets moi je
l'avais eu encore d'autres jours avant
sa peau c'est pas possible dans ma tête
ce n'est pas possible alors voilà il ya
des choses que je savais pas mais bon
j'ai moins c'est pas possible c'est
encore une fois quand tu quand tu voyais
la vie de ceux de ce garçon plein plein
d'énergie même s'il avait des moments
difficiles et christophe allen c'est
vrai que quand janot vous a dit qu'il
acquit la pole et il faut savoir que
janot et nicole ils ont perdu leur
première fille et les enfants d'été
nationale et les parents de christophe
qu'ils ont déjà perdu leur première
question afin de mesurer que moi j'ai
appris cela m'a bouleversé
c'est nationale qui sophie la vidéo il
avait des bas mais pas à ce point là ma
tête je me dis je ne veux pas y croire
alors on va parler livre et on va parler
de la teste j'entends jean dire depuis
tout à l'heure non je vous posais la
même question on passe à la dernière et
jean vous depuis tout à l'heure quand
bernard dit c'est un accident
vous dites non pensez que c'est quoi
alors ce que dit tu sais pas si c'est
pas un accident ça ne nuit pas pour moi
pour moi il sait pas si j'y vais il
avait passé une très mauvaise nuit
il avait il avait une grande impression
donc il était il est en cause est
présent il vous le disais ça y est vous
elle était il avait une dépression dans
l'été il est venu passat est devenu
passé trois mois avec avec nous je les
soigne et on y adonner la médication à
prendre il est prôné j'étais bien là le
mieux
il a voulu remonter son pari et là elle
ne sait pas la psy qui le soigne et
qu'est ce qu'elle lui a donné
qu'est ce qu'il ya comment a évolué le
soigner pensé qu'il n'était pas dans son
état normal n'était pas bien et noir où
je me révolte c'est que pour des
maladies comme ça ce n'est pas elle est
déjà en télé en vidéo nation
moi je pense que déjà cette personne a
redit se déranger pour le soigner sa psy
le suivre oui et si ça n'allait pas le
faire entrer dans une clique et cette
nuit là il avait passé une très mauvaise
nuit
alors je sais pas le matin il va y
mettre d antan ses filles à l'école avec
sa femme la plus grande
[Musique]
je commence pas vous dire papa maritime
et mais pas moi c'est bon et il rentre à
la maison
il avait mal dormir il dit à sa femme
toute la nuit j'ai eu ma semblait que me
tirer dessus j'étais n'était pas bien
j'ai dit j'ai passé une très mauvaise
nuit
ce qu'il avait dit faire au parc de
saint-cloud jogging c'est quoi ces
incessants à la base ce qui n'ont ils je
crois qu'il était parti je conduis non
alors il donne alors didier et bien il
dit alors je ne sais pas comment ça se
passe parce que je ne sais pas mais
j'essaierai de notre savoir et je vais
acheter des cigarettes
il est mal ne laisse pas partir
depuis jean quand j'entends votre votre
témoignage
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont j'en
voulais un peu non acquis aux médecins
aux psys de l'avoir laissée un peu seul
même à moi même avoue même mois moi
aujourd'hui je sais que ma faute c'est
de ma faute
pensez que cela provoque un peu tout
cela pour gelé le dimanche je l'imaginé
qui savent comment ça va
ne sommes pas bien vous l'avez au
téléphone je sais des mots dit samedi
que tu dors bien oui
ne t'inquiète pas ça va très bien après
il me dit que je monte
tu veux que je vienne ne nomme pas si ça
pascal duret qui montrera qu'à voir
après si vous en voulez de ne pas monter
par vous même avant voilà moi je parle
plus dire ma femme juge que sa fille
n'est pas bien il est pas bien je
m'arrête et me prendre je n'ai jamais vu
de forêt même
des fois mal de dents au lieu d'y aller
j'appelle mon dentiste monde dit il en
train de perdre son père il me dit je
veux pas tous comme ça s'est passé
jb je monterai domaines montrent le cma
et donc ça c'est voilà c'est il ya eu un
concours de circonstances qu'il faut
qu'on n'avait pas pu alors j'ai pas
monter mais je réduis j'aurais dû le
faire avant
j'aurais dû le faire avant je savais
qu'il était pas bien bon après ce qu'ils
apprécient les cachets qui devait
prendre et ce qu'il n'a pas pu changer
l'impression pour dit
j'aurais pu on aurait pu tous sauver
tout ce qu'on fait on l'a pas fait oui
exactement
exactement parce que moi je dis
aujourd'hui même somme son docteur
traitants ne vais pas de décisions il ya
douze quand il quand il a eu sa première
dépression je crois qu'il était et toi
berne en 2001 2000 il avait une
dépression et souhait c'est pas que là
il ya même grand docteur zouk qui était
le docteur du stade français qui prend
christophe sonel qui le soigne il fait
faire une cure de sommeil parce que je
pense que ce n'était pas bien dans sa
tête depuis la mort de sa soeur c'est ça
et il ne prend il s'en moque litres
quand il sort de sa cure de sommeil ils
aménagent une chambre chez lui il garde
un mois chez lui à la maison je produis
s'appelle hakim chalabi et ceux là tout
fait pour le remettre en place
quand je l'appelle je l'appelle il était
à au qatar au qatar comme il est et me
disent ah non je viens il me dit on est
comme finir je veux voir avec mon patron
je viens il est venu il est venu et qui
l'aurait sauvé s'arrêter là tu l'aurais
sauver me dit oui j'aurais sauvé parce
qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait et
on n'a pas fait le problème de ces gens
là
moi je pense que pour les petits moi je
parle pour les petits mais j'étais un
numéro mais c'est un numéro et puis
c'est tout et puis on va pas plus loin
monsieur je ne peux pas vous recevoir
jeu vidéo conférence donnée - le numéro
de votre carte bleue est terminée c'est
une maladie je pense qu'il faut voir les
gens faut parler avec faut parler avec
eux mais non non après un prix pareil
pari était pas bien et je pense d'eux
pense que il a eu hélas il y avait eu
par ap parce que l'endroit est pas très
haut
bien sûr il ya un parapet il a dû se
mettre là se pencher pas très bien qu'il
est homme il s'est renversé
parce que s'il avait voulu se suicider
premièrement déjà il aimait trop sa
famille est trop ses filles
il aurait laissé un mot il aurait
[Musique]
peut-être laissé les cdd signe peut-être
je sais pas alors ils m'ont démontré là
dessus sur ce mur il essaie de
s'accrocher et il est tombé dedans on y
trouve les ongles il n'a pas de quoi la
tête
la reine du tout disque quand quentin
quand on a vu la maison funéraire
on a annoncé un jour ils nous l'ont
laissé à le regarder il était magnifique
il nous parlait il est là qu elle est
calme et tous les ans il était non moi
je dire et on aurait pu le sauver
moi et puis je veux savoir la vérité
comment ça s'est passé pourquoi pourquoi
se trouvait là c'est un départ à midi
par à 9 heures du matin ou 10 heures du
matin de la maison 1 et ça arrive à 2h
sais pas pourquoi j'en sais aujourd'hui
vous pensé qu'à ça vous pensez qu à
savoir la vérité
penser ça c'est
ça ne fera pas revenir bien sûr la
vérité je me lasse à voir mais bon j'en
fais pas plus sûr et plus je dirais pas
c'est la faute de l'autre
pas du tout je ferai pas dit un peu
c'est la faute de tout le monde là c'est
ce que vous êtes afin de tout le monde
de tout le monde ne l'a pas soigné parce
que c'est des fal et le sony ouais j'en
merci je peux dire qu'aujourd'hui
christophe dominici bleus à l'âme c'est
réédition de son autobiographie avec une
lettre de jean dominici à son fils et
les témoignages de yann delaigue fabien
galthié max guazzini et bernard laporte
cher que c'est aux éditions du cherche
midi jean franchement votre témoignage
il est incroyable j'espère que vous
allez je sais que christophe vous le
rendra jamais métallier moins avoir la
vérité assez vite et c'était vraiment un
honneur pour moi de vous avoir ce soir
chez nous non agréé mais moi surtout
aujourd'hui où monsieur je me console un
peu psy qu'il est bien c'est bien parce
qu'il était pas bien ils nous faisaient
souffrir était pas d un vip et mais il
n'a pas voulu partir il n'a pas voulu
près sur tout comme bernard dit comme on
connaissait christophe non et puis après
question qu'est ce que voulais s'était
il ne pouvait pas voir quelqu'un est
malheureux si malgré lui
voyez mais vous pensez qu'il est mieux
maintenant moi je pense pour quand vous
l'avez vu puisque vous vous lavez et il
ya un instant et lyon l'a vu il était
bien il était beau il était beau il
était sereine et apaisée tout son monde
et mme bernard et c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de le voir pour la dernière
fois mais c'est vrai quand on le regarde
et avec la peine qu'on avait tous le
voir de saisie les tombes de 10 mètres
il avait rien à la tête ou riez pas il
n'est pas une trace ri quand tu tombes
des divers pseudonymes et bien souvent
ils avaient voulu se tuer regardez se
balancer sur un camion et un train sur
la route
non
il est tombé il est mal tombé christophe
dominici bleus à l'âme avec une lettre
je vous dis de 200 dominici qui l'aï les
témoignages donc de notamment de bernard
laporte max guazini fabien galthié et
yann delaigue merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous voir et on sera à nouveau l'air si
vous voulez vous exprimer ou si vous
voulez venir boire avec plaisir merci
bien sûr montbernard fait partie de la
famille